[Music]
thank you
coming up on FYI our teachers vote to go
on strike but why and how will this
affect us
[Music]
Scarlet sit still to see how this sport
is helping to save our oceans today
we're heading out on the water here in
Bermuda to check out the seagrass
project
foreign
this is FYI the Weekly News show where
we bring you all the latest info on the
big stories and you've probably seen on
the news that some teachers from England
and Wales have voted to go on strike
meaning they won't go back to work on
certain days in the next few months yeah
and some teachers in Scotland have
already started striking haven't they
so basically a strike is usually in
protest over something the workers think
is unfair like other recent strikes some
teachers are walking out over how much
they get paid they think they should be
getting more as food clothes electricity
gas and petrol become more expensive
it's down to the politicians how much
our teachers get paid in an interview
for FYI we ask the education secretary
what the government is going to do to
stop teachers from striking what are you
willing to do to stop high schools from
being closed down by teacher strikes
we're going to pay the teachers a rise
which is between five and eight point
nine percent and it is seen to be the
fair approach but some teachers still
want more and until they can reach an
agreement with the government it's
likely strikes will go ahead and some
schools may be forced to close
[Music]
check out this story that's been doing
the rounds online but is it fact or fake
news
America's President Joe Biden has
supposedly banned gas stoves over
climate change concerns the appliances
are reportedly emitting harmful
pollutants that can be bad for our
health and the environment
is this fake or fact find out later
[Music]
coming up Scarlett finds out how some of
the world's leading Sailors are helping
to save our oceans from pollution
plastic and climate change we're very
lucky to go to our sport to a very high
level but what comes with that is the
ability to have a voice and and to use
that voice for things that you really
care about
it seems everything's become more
expensive recently including household
bills like Heating and electricity and
the main reason for this is because of
the covert lockdown and the war in
Ukraine there's less view available so
the price of gas and oil actually
increased and so have the bills our
parents have to pay
and because of this big oil and energy
companies have been having record
profits we're talking billions of pounds
while so many people have been
struggling to pay their bills yeah and
speaking of oil did you hear that this
year's president of the climate
conference cup 28 has been announced
yeah but not everyone's happy about it
right right so cop 28 stands for the
28th Conference of parties it's a two
week long event where the world's
leaders gather together to try and find
ways to tackle climate change and this
year it's being held in Dubai in the
United Arab Emirates Sultan Alger bear
has been announced as cop 28th president
he is head of one of the world's biggest
oil companies hang on so the person
overseeing the climate change conference
is also overseeing the production of oil
or fossil fuel I mean that's a bit of a
conflict of interest isn't it yeah and
as you can imagine many climate
activists and campaigners are calling
for sultan algebra stand out but it
could be a good thing right it will get
people like him in the conference and
the whole world will be watching to see
what the oil industry does to save our
planet another fossil fuel is coal and
you may have seen the protest at a
potential new Coal Mine in Germany
climate campaigner Greta tomberg was
briefly detained by German police there
and was seen being Carried Away by
officers
[Music]
sale GP like to remind us that they are
powered by Nature
the wind fills the sails of these
high-powered racing boats literally fly
through the waves what a master class at
the start line there but every sport has
some environmental impact especially
International races which need teams of
people and kit to be transported across
the world
[Music]
so can International Sports have a
positive impact they turn the boat now
he's judged it perfectly again
[Music]
I love the sea I think it's beautiful
you can go swimming and snorkeling and
it's home to loads of different species
of fish and we all know how important it
is to protect our oceans and there's
loads of plastic waste in our Waters but
that's not the only threat because of
climate change sea temperatures are
rising and that's killing fish and coral
[Music]
Hannah Mills says her experience of
seeing the effects of climate change on
the sea close up has inspired her to
become an environmental campaigner we're
very lucky to be able to do our sport to
a very high level but what comes with
that is the ability to have a voice and
and to use that voice for things that
you really care about it's a really
privileged position to be in so
sustainability is a huge passion
as well as working with cell GP to get
rid of single-use plastics Hannah has
been working on an interesting project
beneath the waves today we're heading
out on the water here in Bermuda to
check out the seagrass project which is
really exciting project we're going to
be placing some cages over the seagrass
to protect it from the turtles who eat
it
so why does seagrass need protecting
from Turtles the turtles are really
overpopulated here in Bermuda turtles
eat so much seagrass that other animals
that live in the seagrass have lost
their homes so by putting cages over it
it allows it to grow back
as humans we are disrupting different
ecosystems by our activities so to
protect them and to make sure they're
continuing to thrive is really important
one thing I've learned that I didn't
know before is that growing seagrass is
one of the best ways of capturing carbon
from our atmosphere
scientists say that all of the coal oil
and gas that we burn in factories power
stations and cars sends off more and
more harmful gases into the atmosphere
such as carbon dioxide these gases trap
heat from the Sun and around our planet
causing it to heat up that leads to
changing climates such as the UK's
recent heat waves and we can expect more
of them we're told so what's the
solution there are many ways to reduce
the amount of carbon in the Earth's
atmosphere experts say one of the best
weapons are plants plants absorb carbon
dioxide to grow whilst releasing oxygen
seagrass is a type of plant which lives
in Shallow sheltered areas along our
Coast it captures carbon up to 35 times
faster than tropical rainforests
can you imagine
that makes it such an amazing way to
tackle climate change
and cell GP are working with communities
in Bermuda and Plymouth to plant it
I think that sale GP are doing an
incredible job at doing what they can to
protect the environment I definitely
hope that they will inspire other sports
I mean not just because you know they're
such a great Foundation but because of
how much they care about the environment
and they're using their platform to be
an advocate for it I mean they're
planting new sea grass and doing
whatever they can to make it better
foreign
District made out of 200 000 plastic
bricks John Toledo started making this
massive model during the pandemic and
now it's 100 square feet in size that's
the same size as 250 computer tablets
put together
[Music]
we're heading to South Africa for our
next report did you know that there used
to be a system there that discriminated
against black people
up until the early 1990s a white
government enforced was known as
apartheid black South Africans couldn't
vote and they couldn't go to the same
schools cafes Cinemas restaurants or
even live in the same areas as white
people
after Decades of pressure from other
countries and this man Nelson Mandela
who was in prison for fighting against
apartheid the system came to an end Mr
Mandela became South Africa's first
black president
but has the country moved on from this
kind of discrimination yes in many ways
what Ben who watches FYI in South Africa
contacted us with his story which
suggests that there's still a long way
to go
[Music]
this is my mom this is my dad these are
my two sisters and my full nieces hi I'm
Ben and I live in South Africa I know
what you're wondering we look different
how can that be
I'm adopted but my adopted family is all
I've ever known when I was a baby I was
living in an orphanage which was facing
closure but thankfully they found me a
family which I could call my own you see
spices
I would say I love about my mom she's a
very outgoing person and my dad he's the
kind of person that if you're down
you'll make you happy in two seconds
flat my siblings inspire me to do better
not all the time because you know how
siblings are it isn't common in South
Africa cross-racial cross-color adoption
and it should be you know we say we are
a rainbow Nation so why not move rainbow
families it is really hard to be adopted
especially interracial because when we
go out we get stared at and you get
asked very personal questions
it makes me feel uncomfortable it'll
come up to me and ask me is that your
real mom and why is she my color I don't
speak in setswana why don't you speak
that language that I'm letting down
ancestors they'll make me feel horrible
about this I I've decided to do
something about it I've invited my
friends over to explain to them how I
feel
I feel like I don't know what my
Heritage is because I'm adopted maybe I
should stop talking about this more I
think you should I mean we live in such
a diverse country anyways and you're the
epitome of that I mean my mom is British
so maybe I could say I have reduced
Heritage yeah yeah both my parents have
to be so
and Stan where he comes from and I
really empathize with him if you just
look at a few years back when the whole
birthday thing happened we've actually
grown but if you look at household units
like bins you can see unconditional love
you can see skin tone doesn't play a
part your skin kind of it doesn't Define
who you are it's just color like the
colors in your pencil case
it's nothing
if you have a story and want to report
for FYI get in touch via our webpage
even better get your teacher to set up
an FY news club at your school you can
watch and discuss the latest episodes
and get on the program with your views
and reports head to first.news forward
slash FYI
so has Joe Biden really banned gas
stoves in America
the answer is no it's fake news we found
a statement from a spokesperson for the
American government which said they
weren't planning on Banning gas stoves
although measures will have to be taken
if they're not made safer
for info on how to spot fake news head
to our webpage and click on the link for
our I don't get it explainers there's
one on fake news
[Music]
check this out the world's rarest
chimpanzee has been born at Chester Zoo
the critically endangered Western
chimpanzee was born to Mom's easy
it's a small but vital boost to the
global population
now this got us thinking these can be an
amazing place to protect endangered
animals but many people believe they
should be in the natural habitat which
is the wild
so we wanted to give you your shout on
this
over to an FYI News Club in the village
in south Devon said to be one of the
most beautiful Coastal villages with
some of the narrowest streets in the
country with that to hear from an fyr
News Club at Sheldon Primary School
do you think animals should be in Zeus
no because it takes away all that
freedom to do what they want and they
don't have any privacy because of the
people staring at them if like those
Jews are doing like really like good
like conservation work and are trying to
preserve the animals then like yes have
the zoos animals that aren't endangered
should be roaming freely because they
don't deserve to be stuck in like tiny
enclosures usually unless they like
needed like they're being saved I don't
think endangered yeah I don't think it's
needed for them to just capture animals
and put them in cages so people could
look at them I think that people can
learn stuff from Jews but they can also
learn stuff when in their natural
habitat they don't have to be locked up
I think it's good to learn about animals
because if we learn more about them then
that means that we'll know how to take
care of them but if we didn't have zoos
then if people wanted to see these
animals then they'd have to travel
thousands of miles to get there nobody
would like it if they were trapped in a
zoo no so people so animals could look
at you
[Music]
so we know that Janu can be a bit of a
downer so we're going to leave you with
some news that will make you smile yes
so a record number of baby seals has
been spotted on the coast of Norfolk a
total of
3796 seal pups have been born so far
this winter that's more than double than
in 2019. keep the cute pictures see you
next time bye
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Applause]
[Music]